in today's disgusting but totally
unsurprising news Donald Trump allegedly
referred to MSNBC reporter Katie Tours
transgender mom as a [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
dad those are the president's alleged
words so I'm allowed to save him this is
from a new book called sinking in the
swamp by Lachlan Marquis and a so win
sub sang Katie tour is the daughter of
Zoey tour
you might remember Zoey tour from the OJ
Simpson low speed helicopter car chase
in that white Bronco in 1994 if you were
around then Zoey tour doesn't like Trump
and Zoey tour is a trans woman and the
book alleges that Donald Trump makes
horrible comments about women all the
time he called Megan McCain the daughter
of the late Senator John McCain dumber
than her father pointed out that she's
been getting fatter after she said
things on the view that Trump didn't
like this actually started with Trump
getting into it with Katie tore herself
when he was running for president
writing off her questions sometimes
during interviews when he didn't want to
answer one of her questions he would say
oh give me a break next question Katie
very very condescending he started
calling her little Katie started calling
her a third-rate journalist all of that
stuff and once when she tried to follow
up a question with Trump he simply said
be quiet then of course we get to these
latest allegations that Trump referred
to Katy tour privately as again a [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] dad referring to Katy
tours transgender mom this is the
president now he will have defenders no
matter what he says and lots of people
probably agree with him there's a lot of
people in this country I don't know if
it's you know fifteen percent seventeen
percent that are extremely anti-trans
and while they probably would never be
willing to say what Donald Trump is
accused of saying they aren't gonna get
too upset about hearing that Donald
Trump said it that's one group there's
also people who don't necessarily even
agree with Trump attacking trans people
but they do generally want things to
sort of go back to the way they imagined
things were in the 1950s and they see
treating trans people respectfully
something that's not quite in line with
their 1950s ideal so they're not really
gonna get bent out of shape about
attacking trans people but they're not
gonna go and do it themselves and then
of course remember first lady Milani as
Trump's big initiative was going to be
ending bullying fighting bullying and
her husband is one of the biggest
bullies of all sorts of different groups
of people based on their identity that
we know of I wish it weren't the case
but too many people either like comments
like these or they're just indifferent
as long as Trump won't let Mexicans in
the country right or whatever their
priority is it's one of those areas
where we just need to change the
dialogue completely a different
president could do that we talked about
lots of the things that would take a
long time to change and Trump didn't
create racism Trump didn't create
xenophobia or anti trans bias or
anti-semitism but when he says things
like this when he doesn't do anything
about the coalescing and growing
extremist movements he makes the people
who are into those ideologies emboldened
and more comfortable publicly displaying
their beliefs
if Trump leaves the White House in a
year that's not going to change the
views of these extremists but it might
put them back at least in a little bit
of a more hidden position in society
where they might think twice about going
public with these views and then over
time hopefully those views will continue
to dissipate or age out as we like to
say we can hope imagine being Katy tour
and finding out that the president
referred to a parent of yours in this
way it's almost inconceivable or at
least it would have been in 2015 but
this is 2020 United States and this
story barely makes headlines in the
midst of everything else that's going on
really really shocking stuff do you feel
like you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that there are just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire non-fiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free
for a week and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blankest
comm slash Pakman what blinka studs is
take thousands of popular non-fiction
books and condense them into either text
or audio that you can read or listen to
in just 15 minutes and what you get is
all of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to catch and kill by
Ronan Farrow super interesting book
probably already familiar to some in my
audience and a really interesting take
at how Harvey Weinstein and his alleged
transgressions were brought to light
excellent investigative piece Blinky's
has totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for bling cast
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you